هذا واحد من مباني تجاريه وسكنيه عديده في
بغداد وضع القضاء يده عليها في الاونه
الاخيره
وسبب وفق الجهات المعنيه
استخدامها في عمليات غسل اموال واسعه
بسرقه المال العام خلال الفتره الماضيه
غسل الاموال من خلال شراء العقارات تسبب
في ارتفاع جنونين باسعارها
يقولوا تجار العقارات ان سعر المتر المربع
الواحد تجاوز في بعض المناطق التجاريه 20
الف دولار الامريكي
اسعار ضخمه بحيث يعني احنا قعدنا ما نشتغل
لانه يجي المواطن ينصدم بالاسعار
182 مليار يقول رئيس الوزراء العراقي ان
هذه الاموال جزء يسير مما تمت استعادته من
اموال سرقت من المال العام حيث زادت عن
مليارين ونصف مليار دولار في عمليه واحده
قسم الاكبر من هذا المبلغ عقارات
ان ظاهره غسل الاموال تجاوزت حد المعقول
وهذا يعني بان هنالك منظومه
العقارات في العالم سوق المحدوده معروف
وحتى ارتفاع اسعارها تكون وفق معايير
ومحددات هذه الظاهره كثيرا بالعاصمه بغداد
وسكانها في بعض الاحياء التي كانت تشكل
جزءا من جمال العاصمه يتحدث الاهالي
منزعاج كبير كيف تحولت شوارعها الرئيسيه
خلال العامين الماضيين الى مناطقه تجاريه
اما ازقتها فيقول اصحاب الشان ان سعر منزل
صغير فيها لا تتجاوز مساحتهم 100 متر وصل
الى نصف مليون دولار
الامر الذي ساهم في ارتفاع اسعار العقارات
في عموم العاصمه
لا تبدو مكافحه غسيل الاموال في العراق
امرا سهلا منال فتمات اعتقاده سائدو ان
وجود اطراف المتنفذه في المشهد يصعب كثيرا
على الحكومه مهمتها ليس على مستوى القطاع
العقاري فحسب بل في كل المجالات
الاقتصاديه التي باتت بيئه خصمه لمثل هذه
الممارسات وليد ابراهيم الجزيره بغداد